hunter thieves made the decision to let
go of their two newest players from
their violent roster baby jay and eccles
after they only played two official
games with them this decision came after
a weekend where the team suffered a
crushing 13-0 defeat by the hands of the
guard now after this announcement
everything settled down the question in
everyone's mind is
what the [ __ ] happened
hey guys so crazy weekend in the
ballerina world no
regardless we saw the bct challenger
stage continue this weekend we got our
second look at the 2022 100 thieves
valerian roster yeah second this is the
second time we have seen this iteration
of that roster we only saw it one time
before you guys may remember steel being
benched boy coming in then nitro leaving
all fun stuff that i have covered before
but last time we saw 100 thieves compete
was at the last chance qualifier where
they failed to qualify for champions
since then the roster has changed quite
a bit kiko asana and ethan were all
still part of the team but the newcomers
were baby j from faze and eccles who
came all the way from the uk to play
valorant in n.a echols got his visa
approved and was ready to get the ball
rolling baby j called it a dream come
true which it seems like it was we
didn't see them play until the group
stages because 100 thieves didn't need
to compete in the qualifiers so we saw
them first compete in the challenger
stage and things really didn't go well
first 100 thieves lost both maps the
cloud9 blue which to be fair they are
considered one of the strongest teams in
na at the moment but then they faced the
guard they lost haven one split and the
decider was ascent all three players now
for a hundred thieves trying to come out
in the middle of sight one person coming
up from cat there goes the drop from
eccles trent and valinol getting killed
a 4v1 a statement from the guard
13-0 over a hundred thieves
yes you heard that right 13-0
honestly the team comp was
interesting so obviously things needed
to be fixed it seems like even nadeshot
saw that things needed to be changed and
that this should not have been the
result honestly between you and me when
i saw those treats i was like okay
excited to see what they'll do sometimes
things don't work out and a 13-0 might
be pretty indicative of that so you need
to go back to the drawing board and then
the next day i found out what they drew
up while i was playing valerian here's a
reenactment of what happened it's a buy
round i checked twitter and i see 100
thieves tweeted something two minutes
ago i look at it and it's the
announcement of a hundred thieves
dropping baby jane echols from their
roster so i look to this and i promptly
go
what the actual
releasing baby jane echols after two
official games seems like an insane
decision especially a day after a loss
it just seems like a hell of an
overreaction it honestly looked like
hundred thieves saw the drama
surrounding c9 alas in the whole league
situation and were like hold my beard
pros and na were sharing their disbelief
at this decision the news coming a day
after defeat was one thing but dropping
two of your newest players was something
else we found out later that bang and jc
stanley are now on loan and would be
taking the now empty spots sitting here
now it is still so shocking seeming to
be sensing everyone's confusion nadeshot
posted a video to twitter explaining his
side of things in a lot of cases in my
experience of competing sometimes it
really doesn't come down to the talent
and it doesn't come down to the results
it comes down to the culture the mindset
and the philosophy and how the game
should be approached i would say this
was a decision that we felt was
necessary for the success or the
potential opportunity for us to qualify
in the future of 2022 in all the
tournaments that are to come we just
felt like we didn't want to wait out the
inevitable we just felt like the roster
and the players and the way that they
mesh just didn't fit well together and
so you know you got to take a big swing
echols agreed that this was a necessary
decision despite it being disappointing
while baby jace that he felt like his
dream had been ripped from his hands
i'm i'm definitely pissed
you're pissed
yeah
definitely mad you'll kind of like do
you feel betrayed
yeah no for sure i thought
really i got backdoored for sure
you got backdoored yeah no i like
it was pretty blindsided
eccles said he didn't see it coming and
seemed to put the blame on himself
saying as the igl if he could not get
his team to do what he wanted the way he
wanted then that was on him
i didn't see it coming like i wasn't
like okay you're gonna get caught type b
it was like
i understood though that if i didn't
perform well it's not like i can have a
free ride here you know what i mean if
the team didn't have results me as the
igl i need to figure out
a way to get results you know what i
mean
i like obviously
if i i could be saying the correct
things but if i can't get the people to
do them the way i want them then that's
still on me as an igl this is what i'm
learning can i thought it was a man
there
it was my reflection so yeah me as an
idol i need to figure out how to get
the players to do what i want and if
they if i can't get them to do all they
want that's also on me like i could say
the perfect thing but
if i can't get it across to them
then that's also for me to figure out
now in my career how do i get that all
right and now that we've gone over all
of that hi hunter thieves it's elizabeth
how are you i've said this before i'm
not in your practice rooms i'm not in
your scrims and i have no idea what is
going on some information should remain
private since june 2020 you have had 16
players on your team two of them were
dropped after they only played twice
officially like let's say i'm a free
agent and i see this this sends a hell
of a message let's say in this imaginary
world i am trialing 100 thieves and they
offer me a spot
hundred thieves you have given me every
reason to say no to you and very little
reason to consider your offer because as
a player i would be absolutely terrified
like it seems like having a bad game is
absolutely unacceptable and i would be
out of a job why would i say yes to that
offer
to become the next world record holder
of 100 thieves roster speed run getting
dropped any percent seriously though i
think this whole situation underscores
the volatility of esports and the
complete lack of job security at any
point if an orc feels a morsel of
buyer's remorse they're able to
immediately rectify that to satisfy
their anxiety that's showbiz baby and it
sucks that's why it's not surprising
that people are showing reservations
about launching themselves into the
industry i think we have to remember
that all of our favorite talents are
still humans who have a lot of hopes and
dreams and decisions like this can be
incredibly hurtful and scary the new
team made their debut in the knights
tournament recently and all i can say is
i hope the two performed well enough
that they aren't dropped after less than
a week of being on the roster
100 thieves you have given me every
reason to say no in every
very little reason every reason to say
no to an offer and very re
and seemed to put the blame on himself
saying that as an igl
and then the next day i found out what
they drew up
that sounds like threw up
what the [ __ ]
that's funny i'm funny okay